if you wanted to build or produce most
anything i want to think a little bit
about what you would need to do and i
have some pictures here just to get our
imagination going these guys are up to
making something with iron or maybe
making iron bars or making some type of
a thing out of iron and right here is a
an old picture of some planes being made
in a factory but let's just think in
very general terms the things you need
to produce anything
so first of all you're going to need
some land
and that's definitely true if you're
running a farm or if you're trying to
produce timber but you definitely need
land even if you have a factory
obviously both of these factories are
sitting on top of some land
then you're going to need a building
maybe but most probably a building
you're going to need some tools and
equipment
tools and equipment
then you might need some raw materials
in this case it might be iron over here
too you'd need some metal you might need
some electricity or some oil to keep the
the production lines going so you're
going to need some raw materials
raw
materials
and then you're going to need people to
actually work in your factory in this
guy you know these guys putting these
hot bars of iron inside of whatever this
thing right over here is or the people
working on the factory line you don't
see them here this must be off time but
you need people to actually work on the
factory line to tighten bolts and all
the rest of things so you're going to
need labor
you are going to need labor and if you
put all of these things together
if you put all of these things together
so let me put them all together
if you put all of these things together
then
you should be able to produce your
product so you'll be able to output
whatever whatever you set yourself to do
so in the classical sense when you think
about all of these different things that
you might put into production sometimes
they're referred to as a factor the
factors of production
they separate out and this is in the
classical sense they separate out
building and the tools and equipment as
one of the classes so you have land you
have labor and you have buildings and
sometimes just to throw it in there
sometimes you'll throw in management or
organization in here someone needs to
figure out how to lay out all of this
type of thing so this could also be a
factor of production
but buildings and tools and equipment
they're kind of separated out from
everything else
and in the classical sense they're
referred to as capital
they are referred to as capital and they
kind of have this separate distinction
because these are things that are made
by human beings for the specific purpose
of producing other things so obviously
there are other things that are made by
human beings
for example
you could have a
you could have a
let me think of something that's nicely
so a hat a hat is clearly made by a
human being but it's not made to it's
it's not produced to produce other
things it's meant for fashion it's meant
to kind of improve someone's quality of
life but it's not you it's not made to
make other things
in this case the building and the tools
the whole reason why they were made is
to make other things and so the
classical sense they are referred to as
capital
now if we go to kind of more modern
times you'll hear words like you'll hear
words like human capital
human
capital
or financial capital
and you'll see a lot of different types
of capitals that people try to talk
about human capital or financial capital
so what are they talking about because
as in the classical sense capital were
things that people
made so that those things can help us
make other things so the analogy is is
human capital isn't just straight up
labor it plays a role in it but when in
modern times when people talk about
human capital they're trying to make the
same analogy they're kind of investments
made in humans so that those humans are
better at producing other things so
human capital when people refer to it
they're things like education
education
skills
skills
talents
that someone might have talents
experience
experience that someone might have
inside of them or that were invested in
them if you think about the situation of
education
that make them more productive so
they're things that are thrown into a
human being that make them able to
produce more output so this is what
people refer to as human capital and how
it's different than just straight up
labor labor is just look any human being
can go there and move something from one
place to another or pick something up
and put it on a shelf or take it off of
a shelf and put on another shelf but
what human capital is are the
investments in that person that make
them more productive more skilled more
able to do more interesting things the
same thing is true just to throw it in
there just so you can kind of see this
analogy is financial capital you could
just say look there's something like you
know there's money for money sake or
there's uh you know that you could use
to buy a hat or that you could use to
buy really almost any of these other
things but when people talk about
financial capital they're talking about
money that's being used
for the purpose of producing more output
so you could view it as the money that
you actually need to run a factory that
you could that you could um you know for
example they'll call it working capital
it's the the money in the cash registers
that you can actually run your store or
run your restaurant or it could be money
that's put to work by buying a kind of
traditional capital to for buying these
capital goods so that you can produce
more output but the whole idea here i
just want to introduce you to the idea
of capital of capital it's central to
the word capitalism in its classical
sense and then maybe in the more modern
sense especially when people talk about
something like human capital